jeden Tag an mehreren Orten in Berlin
blockieren sie Straßen und
Autobahnausfahrten
wir müssen jetzt handeln wir haben noch
drei bis vier Jahre dann ist es
irgendwann zu spät es fühlt sich
widerlich an ich habe da immer überhaupt
keine Lust darauf auch die Wissenschaft
trägt ihren Protest auf die Straße vom
Labor zum zivilen Ungehorsam gegen den
Klimakollaps
wir haben einfach derzeit Jahrzehnten
als Wissenschaft darin versagt die
Gesellschaft wirklich aufzurütteln die
meisten Leute verstehen immer noch nicht
wie ernst die Lage ist über 100
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
aus ganz Europa sind nach Berlin gereist
sie gehören zur Gruppe scientist
Rebellion stehen für Klimaschutz mit
radikalen Mitteln Nana Maria Grüning
arbeitet eigentlich als
Molekularbiologin an der Berliner
Charité jetzt kocht sie Kunstblut aus
rote Beete-Saft ich habe manchmal
Momente wo ich mir denke so wie kommt es
soweit kommen also wie konnte es dazu
kommen dass ich mich gezwungen fühle
dass hier zu machen ich muss dadurch mit
einem Rollenspiel üben Sie ruhig zu
bleiben zu deeskalieren in
Konfliktsituationen
der Protest soll stören aber friedlich
sein
wir würden niemandem körperlich weh tun
oder
ja niemanden auch verbal beleidigen das
ist auch ein absolutes No-Go wir machen
das halt weil wir gesehen haben das
nichts anderes funktioniert nur wenn
dieser Protest in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft stattfindet bekommt er die
Aufmerksamkeit die notwendig ist um auf
das größte Problem was wir haben zu
weisen nämlich den Zusammenbruch unser
Lebensgrundlagen
stören um die Regierung zu
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen zu drängen das
wollen auch Sie die Aktivisten der
letzten Generation sie fordern ein
Tempolimit und die Fortführung des
neuen-euro-tickets dafür blockieren sie
eine Autobahnausfahrt mitten im Berliner
Berufsverkehr andere Leute wollen zur
Arbeit fahren wegen euch Penner komme
ich jetzt zu spät ja ich verstehe das
okay aber nicht an uns wir sind auch
normal Bevölkerung was haben wir dafür
schuld wenn sie das machen dann muss ich
über ob vor dem Regierung machen
natürlich richten wir uns nicht an die
Menschen hier im Stau sondern wir
richten uns an die Regierung aber wir
haben über die letzten Jahre alles
andere versucht wir waren im
Regierungsviertel wir haben Petitionen
unterschrieben 1,4 Millionen Menschen
waren uns Fridays for future auf der
Straße am gleichen Tag wurde ein
verfassungswidriges Klimaschutzpaket
verabschiedet das heißt der normale
Protest funktioniert nicht wir müssen
jetzt so stören dass wir nicht ignoriert
werden können und das ist leider hier am
besten möglich
die Polizei rückt an und die Blockade
verfestigt sich
wissen warum sie das machen gerade
mein Sohn eine Zukunft hat
weißt du warum ich jetzt hier stehe weil
mein Sohn muss jetzt zur OP und wegen
dir du [__] steht mein Auto jetzt
noch dahin Vater und Sohn nehmen ein
Taxi die Mutter bleibt im Stau die Leute
sind wütend wir werden beleidigt das ist
extrem unangenehm hier zu sitzen keiner
von uns macht das gerne es ist aber viel
viel unangenehmer in 20 30 Jahren in der
Welt zu leben in der wir nicht mit genug
zu essen haben das ist aber das worauf
wir zusteuern wenig später ein
Notarztwagen die Aktivisten machen die
Mitte der Straße frei während die
Polizei ihre Hände mit Speiseöl vom
Asphalt löst und die Straße räumt
am Morgen danach kippt Biologin Nanna
Maria Grüning Kunstblut vor das
Verkehrsministerium die Gruppe blockiert
mehrere Eingänge
dieses Ministerium schafft nicht mal die
einfachsten Maßnahmen einzuführen wie
ein Tempolimit auf deutschen Autobahnen
was alle anderen Länder in Europa
bereits haben vom Minister keine Spur
aber es geht um die Botschaft ziviler
Ungehorsam in weißen Kitteln
Wissenschaft und Aktivismus wie passt
das zusammen
die Wissenschaft das sind die Menschen
die erkennen was man schon alles weiß
wie schlimm es jetzt schon um die Welt
steht wie viel wir schon verloren haben
und die auch die größte riesige
diskrepanzszenen zu der politischen
Ignoranz und Untätigkeit wir
[Musik]
sind auch hauptsächlich
besorgte Bürger und als Wissenschaftler
in der Position in der die
Öffentlichkeit uns auch eventuell ernst
nimmt und und zuhört und deswegen halten
wir es für unsere Pflicht das dann auch
laut auszudrücken auch eine Gruppe von
Eltern ist bei der Aktion dabei Mütter
und Väter die sich frühmorgens auf eine
Straße vor dem Verkehrsministerium
kleben wie Judith Bade ihre Tochter ist
drei Jahre alt
also ich wäre auch lieber zu Hause bei
meinem Kind und hätte es heute morgen
hätte sie heute morgen in die Kita
gebracht und werde morgen bei ihr
gewesen aber ich spüre diesen ganz
starken Drang dieses Verantwortung was
zu tun und mich irgendwie mich stark für
sie und ihre Zukunft zu machen es ist
die Verzweiflung die Sie zu solchen
Aktionen bringt und im Zweifel auch in
Konflikt mit dem Rechtsstaat
nach der Straßenblockade war Jakob Beyer
in Polizei Gewahrsam er wohnt derzeit in
einer WG mit anderen Aktivistinnen und
Aktivisten 180 Verfahren sind
mittlerweile beim Berliner Amtsgericht
anhängig erste Aktivisten wegen Nötigung
verurteilt uns ist bewusst dass wir
potenziell Gesetze übertreten und dass
wir dafür auch rechtliche Konsequenzen
erwarten können
wir sind es aber bewusst eingegangen
weil wir sagen wir müssen größeres Recht
das Recht auf unser aller überleben
durchsetzen der 28-Jährige hat für diese
Art Protest seine Ausbildung zum
Zimmermann abgebrochen macht mit bei
Blockaden und hat sich auch schon an ein
Kunstwerk geklebt
Schlagzeilen macht die letzte Generation
mit einer Kartoffelbrei Attacke auf ein
Gemälde von Monet das Bild sei dank
einer Glasscheibe unbeschadet erklärt
das Museum doch der Aufschrei ist groß
Reaktionen aus dem Netz
schämt euch
Kunstwerke zu zerstören und sich
festkleben um anderen mit solchen
Aktionen auf die Nerven zu gehen hilft
nicht dem Klimaschutz aber auch
verglichen mit der Zerstörung des
Planeten ist ein Monet so etwas wie eine
Lapalie wenn wir in einer drei bis vier
Grad heißeren Welt leben in der es nicht
genug zu essen gibt dann
ist Kunst unser letztes Problem und
deswegen machen wir diese Aktion
deswegen müssen wir Aktionen allen
gesellschaftlichen Bereichen machen
überall da wo wir denken dass wir
Aufmerksamkeit erzeugen müssen und die
rote Linie ist immer da wo wir die
Gewaltfreiheit verlassen würden ich sage
ganz ehrlich ich weiß nicht ob es der
richtige Weg ist also was ich machen
kann und was wir machen können und was
wir versuchen ist halt einfach alles in
unserer Macht stehende was uns jetzt
gerade sage ich mal einfällt und alles
was wir zuletzt gemacht haben hat eben
einfach nicht gereicht
Feueralarm auf der Eröffnungsfeier des
weltgesundheitsgipfels in Berlin
ausgelöst durch klimaaktivistinnen und
Aktivisten
sie protestieren fürs Klima und solche
Sachen
die Klimakrise sei auch Gesundheitskrise
deshalb stören sie die Veranstaltung
wir wollten gerade reingehen aber wir
dürfen nicht reingehen der Polizei haben
erstmal zugeschlossen kein benannte
Grundwert war ein bisschen
am Eingang hat sich der französische
Physiker Sebastian trikenow festgeklebt
wir sind Wissenschaftler wir schlagen
seit 50 Jahren Alarm wegen der
Klimakrise und was ist passiert nichts
also müssen wir jetzt Aktionen
durchführen die sichtbarer und stärker
sind weil wir sagen wir sind am Ende
ziviler Ungehorsam als letzter Ausweg um
durchzudringen mit ihrer Botschaft zu
sehen Sie es vielen ist dieser Weg zu
radikal
ich sage Ihnen ich spreche mit vielen
Leuten Takt täglich wie schaffen keine
Akzeptanz dadurch im Gegenteil sie
machen die Leute wütend
wir sagen wir greifen niemanden
körperlich an wir bleiben strikt
gewaltfrei und wer das Radikal findet
hat wirklich immer noch nicht verstanden
wie schlimm die Situation schon ist
während die Gipfel Teilnehmer abfahren
werden die Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler abgeführt doch für sie
ist klar sie wollen weitermachen